what Rhonda santis did was Banning AP
black history that is going way further
than what many members of my party have
have raised concerns with so there's a
lot of parents who get concerned with
elements of critical race Theory getting
listen I'm going to say this one more
time elements of critical race Theory
are not taught to five-year-olds listen
you know what if you're scared of
American History I
I don't get it what he's doing is so
absurd and it's going so far you're
literally talking about erasing history
this is straight up saying we're not
going to learn about slavery we're not
going to learn about this whole world
everything she said there was a lie they
are not Banning talk about slavery they
are not Banning talk about civil rights
whoopee once again just whoopied the
whole thing meaning she just completely
made things up this has nothing to do
with racism you tell me what gender
queer theory has to do with an honest
assessment of civil rights